hello and welcome to the new world
review source for everything anime and
manga and today we're going to be doing
something a little bit different because
an article was brought to my attention
entitled the untold truth of hunter
hunter which sounded ever so intriguing
because i like truth however i then
realized that the article was published
on
looper which immediately told me that
the truth of hunter hunter was going to
be just a little bit more of a
subjective exploration and what ensued
was one of the most bizarre pieces of
writing that i have ever read if i had
to describe it in one sentence
it's like presenting a book report based
entirely on a trailer for a movie that
you've seen the trailer not the movie
itself that was itself a poor adaptation
of the book so today we're going to go
on a journey of misinformation
misinterpretation and great frustration
that there are people out there like
this who have jobs as professional
writers because this is the untold truth
of the untold truth of hunter hunter
before we dive into it though for the
sake of truth you will need to take the
red pill by subscribing to the new world
review which will result in regular hunt
on content being uploaded straight into
your youtube feed and yes
i suppose you could also take the blue
pill and remain blissfully ignorant of
all of this
glorious content but that's no way to
live now is it
so let's begin in the world of yoshihiro
tagashi's hunter hunter
the most sought after occupation is well
you can probably guess from the title
these hunters are allowed to travel the
world apprehending the most dangerous
villains delving for forgotten treasures
and in the case of gone freaks who
embarked on his hunt career back in 1998
maybe find your dad and make some
friends along the way now i think this
is actually a pretty fine way to
introduce hunter hunter regardless of
what it became this is the premise and i
can't fault the writer for that
the problem is almost everything written
from here onwards while the premise of
the comic is pretty straightforward
hunters hunt things and somehow wind up
being in a seemingly
in the series of battle tournaments and
i have to say this is one of the most
puzzling takeaways that the writer has
when i think of hunter hunter the one
thing that almost never comes to mind is
tournaments and it makes me genuinely
wonder if the author is mistaking hunter
hunter with yuhaka show tagashi's
previous series which is much more
characterized and stereotyped with the
tournament stigma i mean
i guess at a stretch you could say that
hunt hunter has two
tournament style things once during the
hunter exam's final phase and the
short-lived heavens arena but at the
same time neither of those were even
tournaments in the classical sense but
from there nothing else in the series
even comes close to taking on that
format
you know you have the zoldik family york
new city greed island chimera antarc the
chairman election the succession war and
it's all just
nothing nothing to do with tournaments
and all of that together is about 95
percent of the series right there so i'm
already quite perplexed but
let's continue if you've read or watched
hunter hunter and we hope you have
because this article would be a pretty
weird way to get started on it then you
might have noticed something
a little unusual about the way the story
is structured it's essentially a series
of increasingly challenging tournaments
that reveal the strongest people in the
world only to have the next tournament
reveal
someone stronger so i have both read and
watched hunter hunter and i will concur
that this article would be a weird way
to get started on it because the really
unusual thing about the article
is that it completely misrepresents
hunter hunter it starts with the hunter
exam in which only 1
out of every 10 000 applicants is
accepted and even those are winnowed
down by phases that leave only 24
applicants by the time the last one
starts and we just want to pause on this
statement for a second because it is
factually incorrect
by the time the final phase of the
hunter exam began there were only nine
applicants left which i find to be a
really
interesting error to make since the
final phase was a weird tournament which
seems to be the one thing that this
writer pays super close attention to
so i think that's a weird error to make
and it's almost as if the writer maybe
doesn't know what they're talking about
and is confusing the final phase with
the fourth phase
and usually i wouldn't be quite this
petty but at the same time if you're a
paid writer publishing very strong
opinions on a gigantic mega platform
then the very least you should be able
to do is get the facts right
this is the untold truth of hunt hunter
after all and right here we have a
blatant lie of hunter hunter then it
turns out there's a super secret final
part of the exam that happens at the
heavens arena which is full of fighters
so strong that even hunters can't beat
them and here we have some more
delightful misinformation the secret
part
of the exam does indeed exist but it is
not held at heaven's arena gone and
kilauea went to heaven's arena of their
own accord to train at which point gone
encountered wing and began the secret
phase but every other applicant
completed the secret phase in isolated
conditions like karapika who did his
just
randomly in the woods there is no
tournament aspect of the secret phase
and i think there's also a pretty
fundamental misunderstanding of what
hunters are here because almost none of
them participate in heaven's arena in
fact gone and hisoka are the only two to
do so kilauea
technically because he became a hunter
later but if hunters actually did
participate in heaven's arena then they
would wreck
99 of the competitors because that was
one of the key themes of heaven's arena
that these fighters were like the nen
rejects of the world they weren't ready
for it like guido or those who
completely misused it like castro and
all of that is to say once again that
this writer probably didn't pay too much
attention to the series that they feel
so confident about explaining the reason
behind the structure is pretty simple
fighting tournaments have a long and
proud history in shona manga because
they're one of the easiest ways to
introduce new adversaries and get
straight into the big fight scenes
without having to worry about things
like complex plotting or character
motivation
and that's not a criticism and while i
do think that many many fans would
disagree with that last statement sure
let's say it's not a criticism
but that still doesn't make it true and
at this point i just legitimately cannot
comprehend the author's insistence that
hunter hunter is a never-ending series
of tournaments
i did say before that 95 of the series
has nothing to do with the tournament
but that is obvious hyperbole so let's
actually work it out and we will be the
most generous we possibly can be as well
let's say that both the hunter exam and
heaven's arena count as tournament arcs
in their entirety which you can
certainly argue that they don't but
the hunter exam is 38 chapters and
heaven's arena is 20 chapters so
together that's 58 chapters of potential
tournament related content meanwhile
hunter hunter as it stands is 390
chapters long so that 58 chapters of
alleged tournament content
doesn't even make up 15 of the overall
series yet the writer just goes
on and on and on about this never-ending
tournament structure it really is one of
the most baffling things i've ever read
and i can't quite think of a reasonable
explanation for it because other parts
of the article do make it clear that the
writer at least made it to york new city
and even greed island possibly
even further so at this point the writer
does know that what they're saying is
simply factually incorrect but they're
saying it anyway because of
reasons the best explanation i have is
that it would be a condition to activate
the inability which
would make more sense but speaking of i
am very excited to hear their thoughts
on net a power system that can be quite
confusing even when you are paying
attention speaking of nine let's talk
about one of the most notable and
bizarre plot elements that frequently
crops up in the series in its most basic
form nin
is a technique that allows people to tap
into a sort of life force that runs
through all living things
giving those who master its strange
seemingly magical abilities that can
take forms as varied as sensing things
or clouding their adversary's minds or
even shooting out lightning those users
skilled enough to manipulate this force
are called
jedi knights no wait sorry they're just
called nen users got the notes mixed up
there
and i do believe that last part i think
the writer did indeed get their notes
mixed up at all stages of the article
because the only other explanation would
be that they simply did not really watch
or read hunter hunter and not only that
but after completely skimping over the
series they believe that they have the
right to be snarky about it like the
jedi knight comment stuff like that is
kind of infuriating for me to read
because not only is it making it clear
that writer has next to no knowledge on
the subject of none but they're also
making it clear that they don't care to
know either because it's one thing to
make a simple mistake i have made a
whole ton of them on this channel
because hunter hunter is complicated
layered and nuanced especially when it
comes to net
so much more so than you could ever
comprehend on a first reading or viewing
but then again it's a completely
different thing to see killer develop an
electricity-based inability and then
deliberately conflate that with the
force because
well that's another thing you've seen
and you probably didn't take in too much
of that either which is probably why
it's just all the same to you and to be
fair i guess
every power system will act in the exact
same manner if you don't pay attention
to it i mean nobody ever tell him about
devil fruits in one piece because he'll
take one look at an l and call him a nen
user or a force user
it doesn't matter he makes lightning and
it's all the same thing
nen and its users have been exhaustively
categorized over the course of the
series with six types of users
enhancers transmuters emitters conjurers
manipulators and specialists
and complicated mathematical formulas
used by fans for determining how
powerful someone is
so we have some more snarky comments
about the beginning and the end here and
first up i find the use of the word
exhaustive very telling because it
reveals the author's complete and utter
unwillingness to engage with the media
presented the use of that word gives me
the distinct impression that every time
some new information regarding nen was
dropped they would have just thought ah
words how exhausting moving on from that
but at the end here he also makes a
reference to allegedly fan formulas for
power determination and he links to an
article on the hunt pedia specifically a
part that details the equations
regarding nen reinforcement which i need
to emphasize are not
fan made this is entirely togashi's
madness which is actually quite
exhaustively detailed in the series that
you claim to have either read
or watched and furthermore no fans
actually use these especially the
reinforcement and because it's only
relevant for very very specific cases
when comparing enhancement abilities
between differing affinities
and if there is a group of people
talking about that at great length then
look guys i know that hunt hunter has
been on hiatus for two years now but
surely we can still find something
better to talk about than then
reinforcement
it's worth noting that like so many
other things in the world of comics and
manga nen has an
evil opposite this dark side if you will
hey
that's catchy it's called on and was
featured prominently in the 2014 movie
hunter hunter the last mission
and snarky star wars dark side comments
aside quite frankly it's not worth
mentioning at all because the hunt hunt
films are not canon and on never makes
an appearance in the actual series which
i only bring up because once again this
article is called the untold truth of
hunter hunter
and this is the latest piece of
misinformation in a block of writing
allegedly dedicated to conveying the
truth now with all of that said the
article
isn't all bad when the writer is talking
about the background of the series like
the hiatus struggle and togashi's
relationship with naokotakuchi that's
all really good and fun stuff to read
and it's also very appropriate given the
title of the article however when
explaining hunter hunter itself this
is an utter dereliction of duty and
quite frankly a profoundly embarrassing
mess and i obviously don't want to dox
this guy but he is an
actual writer like he puts words to page
as a profession he gets paid to do this
mainly for western comics and i believe
that he is something of a batman expert
in particular all of which is very cool
by the way that sounds like quite an
amazing profession however i really do
think you should probably stick to that
area
because i imagine that if i made a video
titled the untold truth of batman
without ever having performed a passing
glance of research and just making
snarky comments then he would probably
rip me apart
and quite rightfully as well mind you
because i know hardly anything about
batman
certainly not enough to offer an article
presenting the untold truth behind the
series
i do however know about hunter hunter
though more than enough to know that
there is very little truth in this
article claiming to be conveying truth
it reads more as highly subjective
ramblings of a flawed experience of a
series that the writer clearly did not
enjoy going through sprinkled in with
some fun facts about background
production and wrapped in a click bait
titled package with that said it is
still far from the worst written article
out there
all of those honors belong quite firmly
to cbr because
oh dear but what do you guys think
please do leave your thoughts in the
comments below or even join my discord
server and if you're keen for some more
hunt hunter content then please to go
and check out some of my other videos or
even subscribe to the channel
for regular hunt hunter glory delivered
straight into your youtube feed but for
now this has been the new world review
and i'll see you next time